what do you think caused this like this  weird relationship with food do you have  any idea  food was restricted for most of my life  and so  the way i got around that was sneaking  food and so i developed this kind of  like  you know was pleasurable for me to  eat as much as i could when nobody could  see me because  i couldn't otherwise eat the amounts  that i wanted now  i go deep into thinking about this and  think that when food be  began being restricted for me i wasn't  obese certainly i was i was overweight  and that was why  i was initially put on diets as a kid  and had i just had i just understood the  point  maybe this wouldn't have happened